[संगीत]
हेलो भाई लैंग्वेज
तो आज का जो सेशन है वह शायद बड़ा हो सकता
है
मतलब मैंने भी जब यह पढ़ा था टॉपिक वो सब
टीवी बहुत टॉपिक कन्ज्यूरिंग टाइप से करके
मैंने कल भी जल्दी छोड़ दिया था की यार आज
का टॉपिक नेक्स्ट था तो अगर मैं कल के साथ
ही अच्छा बनाऊंगा तो फिर कल का भी थोड़ा
ऊपर नीचे से हो जाएगा क्योंकि क्योंकि
दोनों टॉपिक सिमिलर्स हैं बट फिर भी
कुछ है जो अलग-अलग है
ठीक है फिर अपन चालू करते हैं हमारा देश
है
मतलब
जॉइन करता है उनके कोई भी लॉजिकल
रिलेशनशिप
बोलते हैं
तो वैसे अपन दो टेबल्स के साथ में ए सकते
हैं
तो वह चीज के बड़े में आज अपन जानेंगे
थोड़ा अच्छे तरीके से
यह क्या होता है
आप लोगों को
क्या
तो सबसे पहले
ठीक है
यह थोड़ा सा इंर्पोटेंस
तो मेरा सॉरी
करना सीखेंगे
तो क्रिएट टेबल
कोर्स बना लेते हैं
कोर्ट से बड़ा बड़ा नाम नहीं लिखेंगे
न्यू
तो यह मेरे टेबल
डालेंगे
ठीक है यह जो मैसेज बता रहा हूं यह सच में
फीस नहीं है
लेकिन मैं यहां पर बता रहा हूं बस और कुछ
नहीं है यहां पर मैं एसक्यूएल लिख देता
हूं
ठीक है और यहां पर
ज्यादा बड़ा हो जाएगा
[संगीत]
ठीक है
स्टूडेंट का
स्टूडेंट
[संगीत]
ठीक है तो टेबल अभी बन गई है
6 जनवरी
एक और विशाल
उनको प्रणाम
[संगीत]
एम्पलाई थोड़ी है अभी तो स्टूडेंट
ठीक है
आपने
इक्वल तू ऑपरेटर वगैरा लगता है ठीक है ना
दो कलर दो टेबल से जॉइन करते हुए हम जो
कलम का फील्ड बिल्ड है वो सब कुछ से होना
चाहिए तो देखो ये इन दो टेबल के साथ
कांड करने वाला हूं सबसे देखो इसके अंदर
अपना कोर्स आईडी जो था
वो इंटीरियर था यहां पर कोर्स आईडी है जो
अपने अंत में अपन लिया हुआ है तो इसका रेट
अगर से है तो इनके साथ में जो भी देख सकता
हूं
ओ हो तो बढ़िया चीज है अगर पैसे मेरे को
पसंद हो तो मुझे पैसे में बहुत ज्यादा
पसंद है
तो यहां पर
का नाम लिखना हूं कोर्स
आईडी है
स्टूडेंट टेबल
मतलब सीन क्या है ठीक है ना तो देखो
सिलेक्ट स्टार फ्रॉम स्टूडेंट और कोर्स
डाला मैंने यहां पर तो इसका क्या मतलब हुआ
की सिलेक्ट सब कुछ दिखा दो अपना स्टूडेंट
ऑफ कोर्स में से जहां पर स्टूडेंट की टेबल
में से जो अपना कोर्स आईडी है उसका जो
कोर्स आईडी है वो अपना कोर्स के कोर्स
आईडी से मैच खाना चाहिए तो देखो क्या क्या
है यहां पर इसने गेम्स का जो तन था ठीक है
ना वो यहां पर इसने भी इसका भी कोर्स नहीं
निकाला साथ में दिखाए था नेटवर्किंग इसका
फिर से अपना तीन इधर 500 तो यहां पे देखो
20 आया यहां पर मोहम्मद कैफ भाई का पाइथन
का फिर 3000 फिर 30 का 25000
की जगह पर भी लिखा होता तो आप इसको रिपीट
होता है वहां पर ठीक है ना बट ऐसा हो गया
लेकिन आप इसके अंदर एक चीज नोटिस कर सकते
होंगे की जो 106 वाला था अपने आयुष हाय का
वहां पर एडिट डाला हुआ था मतलब कोई यहां
पे थोड़ी नाम का तो नंबर से कोर्स है ही
नहीं ठीक है ना तो इस चक्कर में आउटपुट भी
नहीं दिखाए है क्योंकि जब थोड़ी ना कोई
कोड सही नहीं तो अपनी ये वाली जो कंडीशन
है ये कंडीशन हो जाएगी
मेरा पेन निकाल लेट हूं
यह अपना स्टूडेंट टेबल है इसका जो कोड
साड़ी लिखा हुआ है
वह मैचिंग करना
चाहिए
वहां पर आउटपुट दिखाना चाहिए ठीक है
ना इसके कोर्स
यहां पर इसके मैचिंग के हिसाब से यहां पर
इस टेबल का आउटपुट शो कर रहा है ठीक है
हां जो मैसेज नहीं उठा देगा सही का रहे हो
यह हो गया अपना इक्वेशन
ठीक है
राइट वाला यह करेगा राइट का पूरा टेबल का
दिखाएगा और लेफ्ट आम वाला चीज दिखाएगा ठीक
है
वो अपना राइट का सब कुछ दिखेगा और लेफ्ट
से ओनली आम दिखाएगा
दोनों टेबल में आउटपुट दिखाएगा
ठीक है
तो करते हैं
ठीक है चलो मैं ना पहले पुराने वीडियो
मैंने आपको एक सिंपल सा चीज दिखता हूं की
यार आगे बढ़ाने से पहले
लिखा है यह कोर्स लिखा है तो अपन स्टूडेंट
जितनी बार अपन कंडीशंस एड करते रहेंगे
क्योंकि देखो अपने और और वाली कंडीशन भी
लगा सकते हैं क्योंकि अपुन वेयर ऑपरेटर का
उसे कर रहे हैं वेरी के साथ हम कुछ भी चीज
लगा सकते हैं वैसे ही कंडीशन चलेगा जैसा
रबर कंडीशंस चला है तो देखो अपुन को हर
बार student.com आईडी कोड डॉट कोड साड़ी
ऐसे करके लिखना पड़ता है ठीक है ना अगर
मैं चाहूं की यार मैं कैसे भी करके टेबल
का नाम छोटा कर सुकून तो उसके लिए मैं
क्या करूंगा ना ये टेबल के नाम के आगे
स्टेप आइस नाम दे दूंगा ठीक है ना
स्टूडेंट
का मतलब ऐसे बताएंगे कोर्स सी
ठीक है
कम कर रही है
अब मैंने इसने स्टार की जगह
फैन कॉपी करके पेस करता हूं तो यहां पर
मैं क्या लिख सकता हूं मुझे ना एस से
एस डॉट मुझे यहां पर नाम चाहिए
नामा
आईडी चाहिए कॉमर्स सी डॉट सी नाम चाहिए और
सी डॉट
सी सही है
मगर
स्टूडेंट लिखना पड़ता तो उसे चीज से बचाने
के लिए मैंने यहां पर
अच्छा ग रहा है
सीधा मतलब
दो बार दिखे रहा था
सिलेक्ट
स्टार
लगाने का मैं चाहता हूं
तो वह कोई दिक्कत वाली बात नहीं है अच्छा
अच्छा रेस्टोरेंट
जो अपनी लेफ्ट साइड जो टेबल थी उसे टेबल
के सारे रिकॉर्ड दिखा रहा है लेकिन राइट
वाले टेबल से वही रिकॉर्ड दिखा रहा है जो
रिकॉर्ड लेफ्ट पर ही टेबल से मैचिंग हो
रहे हैं ये मैंने लेफ्ट आउटर रिंग के बड़े
में आपको बताया था साइड के अंदर वही चीज
यहां पर हो रही है लेफ्ट वाली टेबल साड़ी
दिखा रहे हैं यहां पर
ठीक है लेकिन राइट और ये टेबल से सिर्फ
उतना ही रिकॉर्ड दिखा रहा है जितना
रिकॉर्ड इसके साथ में मैचिंग है
अगर मैं यहां पर देखो यहां पर ना इसके
अंदर एक है ना 15 एम का भी एक और अपना वो
बता 54 साड़ी में था वो उसने यहां पर नहीं
दिखाए है
क्योंकि ये लेफ्ट आउटर जॉइन का मैं इसके
अंदर उसे कर रहे हैं तो लेफ्ट आउटर जो
इनके अंदर अपना वही राहत है ठीक है
इसके सारे रिकॉर्ड दिखाना और ब्राइट वाले
टेबल से ओनली मैचिंग रिकॉर्ड दिखाना बस
यही इसका कम होता है
ठीक है
अब अपन जाते हैं अपना राइट तरफ से
जगह
पे ऑन वन लगता है ठीक है ना ऑन करके ऐसे
लिखा होता है ठीक है ना तो उन चीजों पर भी
आप लोग गौर करते रहना अपनी तरफ से भी चीज
क्या चल रही है क्या हो रही है ठीक है ना
यहां पर लेफ्ट वाली टेबल दिखाएं
अगर मैं राइट टेबल के हिसाब से रेड टेबल
के सीक्वेंस के हिसाब से लेफ्ट वाली टेबल
का आउटपुट ए रहा है वह भी आप चीजों को आप
लोगों को थोड़ी सी डर से समझ में ए रही
होगी लेफ्ट वाले अपना राइट वाले का अपना
पूरा का पूरा डाटा दिखा रहा है यहां पर
ठीक है ना सारे रिकॉर्ड दिखा रहा है जो
मैचिंग नहीं है राइट से लेफ्ट से जो
मैचिंग नहीं है मैं थोड़ा ज्यादा डब्बे बन
गया यहां पर
जो राइट टेबल के अंदर रिकॉर्ड मैचिंग नहीं
है लेफ्ट से ये 50 वाला रिकॉर्ड मैच नहीं
है अपने लेफ्ट से
फिर भी यहां पर दिखाए
गया है
जो राइट वाला था इसके अंदर यहां पर 106 था
उसे भाई का जिसका 40 लिखा हुआ था कोड आईडी
वो अपने कोर्स के टेबल में था ही नहीं तो
वो रिकॉर्ड यहां पर नहीं शुरुआत क्योंकि
वो इसके साथ मैचिंग में नहीं था
ठीक है
नहीं मैचिंग है कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता
है
मतलब इस टेबल के कम के हिसाब से टेबल के
रिकॉर्ड दिखाएं
के बड़े में सबको समझ में आया की नहीं
बताओ फिर मैं आगे बढ़ता हूं आगे अपना
क्रॉस जॉइन भी है अभी इधर जॉइन भी है
सेल्फ जॉइन भी है अभी
पहले जॉइन
सिंपल लिक्विड जो मैंने पहले बताया था
अभी तक बैलेंस कर चुके हैं समझ में आया की
नहीं
दो-तीन तरह
समझ में आना है बहुत जरूरी है
चलो ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
आगे बढ़ते हैं
अपना चेक करो
या कुछ ऐसा कंडीशनर र जाते हैं तो उसे
कैसे में क्रॉस जॉइन अपना हो जाता है ठीक
है ना वह दिखता कैसा है
जैसे मैं सिलेक्ट स्टार
फ्रॉम स्टूडेंट कोमा कोर्स अगर यहां पर कर
डन
और दूसरे वाले के अंदर कितना रिकॉर्ड्स था
कर
रिकॉर्ड इसने अपने को दिखाएं हैं
देख सकते हो प्रोग्राम
की कैसा गलती होने का दिखता है
और एक और तरीका भी है यहां पर
भी लिख सकता हूं तो यह यह तबीयत अपना
हसबैंड होगा
यह प्रॉब्लम होगा
टेबल से कुछ कंडीशंस अपनी ही टेबल में
मिलकर सामने दिखाने की है मतलब एक कलम से
दूसरे कलम के अंदर कंडीशन मिला के दिखाने
की है तो उसे कैसे के लिए भी अपने पास
सेल्फ जॉइन रहते हैं
क्या होता है
की अगर किसी कंपनी का कोई एम्पलाई है मतलब
जैसे की अगर आप किसी कंपनी में मैनेजर हो
तो तू देखा जाए तो आप उसे कंपनी के
एम्पलाई भी तो हो तो मतलब आप एम्पलाई टेबल
के अंदर भी आओगे
उसे टेबल के अंदर ये भी लिखा हुआ रहती है
कौन आपका मैनेजर है ठीक है तो क्या होगा
इस कैसे के अंदर की अपने एक ही टेबल के
अंदर मैनेजर की लिस्टिंग हो राखी है और एक
ही टेबल के अंदर अपने एम्पलाई के सक्सेस
के आगे मैनेजर का आईडी भी लिखा हुआ है ठीक
है
तो कौन किसका मैनेजर है वो अपन को एक ही
टेबल के अंदर लिखा हुआ है बट अपुन को उनके
नाम के साथ में चाहिए की यार ना ये एक
इसका मैटर है कौन किसका मैनेजर है वो कैसे
होगा वो के वो अप सेल्फ जॉइन से करते हैं
क्योंकि अपनी एक ही टेबल के अंदर कुछ ऐसे
रिकॉर्ड्स हैं
जिनको अपन को एक दूसरे से चेक करवाने का
है जैसे की एम्पलाइज से मैनेजर को चेक
करवाने का क्योंकि मैनेजर भी अपना एंपलॉयर
टेबल
क्रॉसिंग भाई कुछ नहीं एक गलती से होते
हैं
या बुरी कंडीशंस देने के चक्कर में होते
ऐसी कंडीशन दे दी जो ऑलवेज ट्रू हो रही है
मतलब यहां पर हमने कुछ कंडीशन ऐसी कंडीशन
जीरो दी जो ऑलवेज ट्रू हो रही है या फिर
आपको कंडीशन देना भूल गए हो उसे कैसे के
अंदर आपका क्रॉस जॉइन होता है ठीक है ना
क्रॉस जॉइन के अंदर हर चीज एक दूसरे से
मिलने दिखाई जाति है की ये इसके इक्वल ये
इसकी इक्वली उसे का रिकॉर्ड उसे का
रिकॉर्ड उससे इसका रिकॉर्ड इसका रिकॉर्ड
तो हर चीज एक दूसरे से मिला के दिखाने के
चक्कर में अपना एम*एन हो जाता है ठीक है
एम अपना एक टेबल है एन दूसरे टेबल है ठीक
है ना तो मतलब एक टेबल के अंदर अपने 6
रिकॉर्ड है दूसरे के अंदर अगर अपने कर
रिकॉर्ड है तो फिर 6 * 4 24 अपने को फिर
रिकॉर्ड्स दिखाएं जाएंगे
है तो अपने एम्पलाइज टेबल बनाएंगे
तो इसको मैं बैंड राहत हूं और उनके साथ
में आप पर
एक कम करते हैं
और एक और कोई नहीं यार
अपने विशाल भाई है
सेक्स भाई वह किसकी मैनेजर नहीं है
एमपी आईडी =
2 अलग-अलग टेबल है
टेबल का मैनेजर
ढंग से लिख देता हूं
ठीक है
तो यह उल्टा पान को पढ़ने में ए रहा था
फिर नेक्स्ट अपना रोहित भाई के मैनेजर
अपने विशाल है
आयुष का अपना मेज रे रोहित विशाल
निकाल सकते हैं
पहले वैसे इतना मतलब पहले अपना लेफ्ट के
अंदर मैनेजर
आपको लास्ट लेक्चर
समझ में आया की नहीं
बताओ यार समझ में आया है की नहीं आया
तो अभी आते हैं
ठीक है
स्टूडेंट
कोर्स आईडी
लिखा है
ठीक है इसमें क्या कहना सारे रिकॉर्ड
दिखाएं
यहां पर अपने को ठीक है क्योंकि देखो
आउटलाइन क्या होता है लेफ्ट वाले आउटर
रिंग के अंदर क्या होता है लेफ्ट के सारे
रिकॉर्ड दिखा रहा है राइट से नहीं मैचिंग
वाले दिखा रहे हैं रेड के अंदर राइट के
साइड रिकॉर्ड दिखा रहा है लेफ्ट में
मैचिंग वाला दिखा रहा है
मैच हो रहा है तो भी दिखा रहा है नहीं हो
रहे तो भी दिखा रहा है लेकिन क्या कर रहा
है ना वही रिकॉर्ड दिखा रहा है जो रिकॉर्ड
मैच हो रहा है
जो मैच नहीं कर रहे हैं रिकॉर्ड वो
रिकॉर्ड नहीं दिखा रहा है ठीक है ना तो
इन्होंने क्या कर रहा है जो रिकॉर्ड से
मैच हो रहे थे वही वाला रिकॉर्ड दिखा रहा
है ये अपना कम होता है दोनों टेबल
दिखाएगा जो रिकॉर्ड मैचिंग हो रहा है उसके
अलावा
सबको समझ में आया की नहीं
बताओ यार समझ में आया है की नहीं आया है
ठीक है
उसके लिए मैं क्या कमांड लिखूं जल्दी मुझे
बताओ यहां पर मैंने बता राखी थी जो लोग
पहले से है
चलो कोई नहीं बता रहा है तो मैं खुद यहां
पर लिखना हूं
तो आप टेबल टेबल
पर
बनाऊंगा
तो उसे कैसे में मुझे इन दोनों के बीच में
एक रिलेशनशिप बनानी पड़ेगी जो अपना
आरडीबीएमएस होता है
ठीक है ना
वह कम करता था
सबसे पहले तो कोर्स वाला टेबल था
अब देखो
एंट्री करूंगा
नेटवर्क
वाला जो अपना पार्ट है
इसके अंदर यह वाला जो कोर्स होना चाहिए ये
अपना कनेक्ट हो जाए अपना कोर्स टेबल की
कोर्स आईडी से ताकि जब भी कोई इसके अंदर
डाटा के एंट्री करें और कोर्स आईडी के
एंट्री करें तो वो जाके सीधा कोर्ट से
टेबल में जाकर चेक करें क्या रे कोट्स
आईडी पहले से एडजस्ट करती है की नहीं अगर
एडजस्ट नहीं करती होगी तो वो कोर्स के
एंट्री नहीं करने देगा ठीक है तो अपन उसको
करके देखते हैं एक बार
कोड सेटिंग दाल दिया है यहां पर
ठीक है ना अब देखो है ना इसके लिए सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज क्या होती है की दोनों को
डाटा टाइप से होना ठीक है तो कोर्स आईडी
जो अपना स्टूडेंट के अंदर है उसके रेट है
और जो साइज है वो डिफॉल्ट है और जो अपना
कोड से है उसके अंदर
तो चलो उसके आगे अपन करते हैं तो मैं भारत
आइडिया वाले जो चीज है इसको पोर्ट्स वाली
टेबल की फोर्स आईडी से मिलन चाहता हूं तो
यहां पर लिखूंगा
डिफरेंस
टेबल है जिससे मुझे मिलन है तो वह
टेबल के कोर्स आईडी से मिलन चाहता हूं
देखो जरूरी नहीं है की यहां पर कोर्स मतलब
कलम का जो नाम है वो से हो अपने दूसरी
वाली टेबल कलम के नाम से जरूरी नहीं है
बिल्कुल भी दोनों का डाटा टाइप से होने
चाहिए ठीक है इन चीज का थोड़ा प्रॉपर
ख्याल रखना
स्पेलिंग
बताइए कहां पर मिस्टेक है तो वहां से अपन
सॉल्व कर सकते हैं
ठीक है तो अभी मैंने ये टेबल को इससे मिला
दिया है अब जो इसका डाटा था
ने का ट्राई करता हूं
चला गया
20 वाला यह भी चला गया
था और अपने जो सिलेक्ट स्टार फ्रॉम कोर्स
इस टेबल के अंदर
कोर्स
एकदम बढ़िया है उसके बाद भी की हुई है तो
आप मतलब उसके साथ आगे ये भी देखो की वो
टेबल किस कनेक्ट है वो जो कलम में किस से
कनेक्ट है फिर वो टेबल खोल के देखो ये
टेबल खोल के मैंने देखा है यार ये तो
डालने की कोशिश कर रहा है वो साला यहां पर
है
तो इस कैसे के अंदर यह 40 वाला डाटा
डालेगा ही नहीं
राहत है
तो यह आपका आज का टास्क है आपको टास्क
करने के बाद में क्रोम पर जान का है
आपको
पोस्ट के अंदर
जैसे यहां पर दे तू का डाला हुआ है डेट 3
का भी है ठीक है ना वैसे यहां पर
अपना दे 7 का भी ए जाएगा तो आपको उसके
अंदर आपको करके दिखाना आपको स्क्रीनशॉट
खींच के भेजना का क्या मतलब फैंसी
इंटीग्रिटी कर दी है अच्छे से और साथ के
अंदर मैंने वो भी कर दिया है क्या नाम है
दो से अधिक केवल इसके साथ में मैंने जॉइन
का भी इस्तेमाल कर दिया है तो आपको ये दो
चीज करके आपको स्कैनर स्ट्रेंजर खींच के
भेज देने की है ठीक है ना अगर आपको एरर
आता है तो जरूर हम लोग यहां पर बैठे हैं
ठीक है
जो भी लिंक है वो आपको सारे के सारे युटुब
के जो वीडियो अभी चल रही है लाइव इस लाइव
वीडियो के अंदर भी आपको यहां पर
भी हमारे इंस्टाग्राम
ठीक है
आज उनको फर्स्ट करना पड़ेगा प्लीज मतलब
जिन्होंने फर्स्ट सेशन नहीं देखा है वही
सेशन मतलब फर्स्ट जॉइन करो ताकि आपको चीज
समझ में आए तो आपको ऐसे लाइफ के नीचे
रहेगा
वहां पर आप आकर जो भी अभी क्वेरीज वगैरा
है वो आप देख सकते हो ठीक है ये एकदम चैनल
को जॉइन कर लेना और जॉइन करने के बाद में
उसका डिसीजन भी जॉइन करना कहानी दिखता है
तो डिस्कशन में आप अपने दिक्कत वगैरा दाल
सकते हो ये डिसीजन
कर दूंगा नहीं तो अगले दिन के लेक्चर में
उसको जरूर कर करने की कोशिश करेंगे ठीक है
थोड़ी और हैवी होने वाली है ठीक है मतलब
और अच्छी खासी हैवी चीज बैंड करेंगे आगे
तो एकदम
करने का तो वही चीज है तो बस आज के लिए
इतना ही सबको डाटा बाय बाय थैंक यू
अगर फिर मिलेंगे अगले लेक्चर में कल
सो बाय बाय टाटा सी यू सुन
गुड नाइट और जय हिंद वंदे मातरम